okay let's go
the next speaker is Ramon Navarro Bosque
CTO in onna IO it's very well known in
the open-source community also from the
member of the framework team of plum and
then so flow engineer and thank you very
much and his talk will be about Gil
Athena an Isaac rest resource DB to
manage millions of objects thank you
very much thank you very much well you
nearly said everything about me I'm
co-founder and CTO of owner is a San
Franciscan Barcelona company our main
mission is to connect and search all the
knowledge inside an enterprise using
machine learning this kind of Google but
for inside the company with all the
resources connectors all the places
slack Dropbox Google Drive or whatever
connecting everything and being able to
search we just got garner pointed as one
of the commanders of this year and I'm
really enthusiastic about open source
I've been on open source nearly 20 years
and a member of the plum foundation us
condition for open source and also on
the framework team of this loan software
and I'm a web primal engineer so I'm not
a data scientist so my main goal for
this talk is that you don't kick ask me
of this stage before I am the
photographer good
I really want to try to we try it with
the software to build something that
it's from both worlds web web
environment and data scientist so first
a bit of background one of the most
common problems we are facing on when we
are doing data scientist or where
whatever algorithm we want to do is that
we need to have this data we need to
clean the data we need to get the data
and normally it's a big fight between
engineer
that means that have a database or have
a lot of data and the data scientists at
one the CSV file I want I just want the
CSV file but the data I think this is
squirrel whatever place I need to
extract I need to oh my god this is
going to take me one month to do this
work no and this is one of the most
common problems that we are facing and
it's an engineering problem so we are
trying to find a solution for this
problem I'm not having a fight so we are
friends there the other background idea
is that most of that assignment is all
always thing about tables no see SBS row
column net information information that
is a structured on kind of categorical
numerical variable and in the table our
users love that for data tables but the
wall outside on the engineering outside
it's more a bit more complex we have non
structured data we have JSON data we
have documents we have information that
has multiple levels of nested soup
information
so our what I am on this plane it's more
oriented to the known as well wall where
information is not a structured in a
table and can dynamically change
tomorrow we are adding a new field we
are removing one field etc so what
happens with web frameworks right now
well web frameworks are nearly dead from
the point of view that rendering a page
an HTML page nobody right now is
focusing on building web frameworks that
renders in HTML and add the CSS and this
kind of things either Django for example
one of the most committed representation
jungle is the REST API because everybody
knows that all CMS's all for web
frameworks needs to provide a REST API
and there is a lot of really good
technologies in front of that angular
and react for example that allows you to
build the front-end the user experience
from the user
we really don't need to develop the
rendering on the back end so what will
happen with these web frameworks jungle
what ipm8 blown that will then we need
to evolve to a rest api and at the end
it's a data framework it's a place where
you push information and you get
information and you can modify
information so it's more connected to
the data and all the web developers all
the web engineers that there is around
all these projects they have a lot of
knowledge or the scalability about the
storing information how to do optimal
things on on production environments and
I think it's really important that we
connect this to world and we we make
options to to have the web framework
connected to the data scientist back-end
so this is my main goal with with godina
is that the web framework communities
and the data scientists communal
communities can live together and they
can work to have connected life data web
frameworks with that design these
frameworks so the same place where the
real that is one is pushed where the
vacation is it's managed where the
engineering team the production team is
pushing the information it is in place
where the data scientist can get the
data and process training models and
they can do inference and whatever it
needs to be done there so first I'm
going to also be in the context of what
skills dinner I need to go back in
history I need to go 18 years ago the
worst job and the udb
was created was created by the
corporation with a corporation had to
kind of lead engineers you may know
given drusen the greater of Python so he
was working on soap and he was one of
the greatest observe with Jim Fulton who
created the Zoo TV at an object database
oriented to store information in a
mode so they created this piece of
software 18 years ago
Python was not an early to 2.0 version
so it was they needed to build
everything Python has no libraries
nearly so so needed to book all the
needed workarounds to solve the problem
the Python had at that moment and it was
a really good piece of software
enterprise-oriented with a lot of
security and it was a way to to have an
application running on your on your
servers 16 years ago plum was created
loan is a CMS that it's a layer on top
of October does anybody does not know
what it CMS content management system
it's kind of everybody's going to kill
me if I say that that it's kind of a
wordpress but for enterprises okay so
it's a really good piece of software a
dream there for 16 years a lot of big
companies are using that for managing
the content inside internet different
kind of applications CMS web ecommerce
applications a lot of things are built
on float 7 years ago the guys that were
still on joke decided to do something
new they called it parameter and they
merge framework is called pylons and
repose be a sphere
BFG that is a joke fork then two years
ago the plum community that it's quite
it's 500 more or less active developers
there they decided to build a REST API
because there was kind of seeing what I
said at the beginning that web
frameworks are dead in the in the terms
of rendering content from from the
backend so they build the REST API and
it really works very well it's really
stable it improving a lot and it's a
really good piece of code but the
problem of clone is that has 300 Python
X packages
so because it's so big it's been there
for 16 years that there is a lot of code
there a lot it is not impossible to
maintain that kind of see so one year
ago a group of people inside the bloom
community decided to write the write
from scratch all the blown back end
using only Python 3.6 and I think of you
as the main engine to to serve request
so we decided to take everything that we
haven't blown all the knowledge all the
expertise that there is there for 16
years
enterprise-oriented and create a new
framework that we call blown server at
that moment however a year ago somebody
was kind of annoying us saying if you
call it blown it's like it's flow but
it's not blown so we decided to change
the name and we create a deal Tina we do
dinner it's a framework oriented to
create rest api's that it's based on a
single with Python 3.6 and it manages
all the data modeling of all the
standard fields so I'm going to go a bit
over the functionalities of cadena and
what it's exactly so the first point is
that it's transactional
so everything that you do on the API
from guillotine ER it's going to be
persisted on the database and we can
assure that it's going to be there so
there is no possible of losing
information or kind of not confirmed
writings on the database it also
provides comfortable resolution if two
people are writing to the same object at
the same time it provides a way to solve
the consider all the information on on
this REST API it's stored on a tree URIs
URLs are a tree based kind of model if
you go to a slash a slash B as I see on
a URL it's at the end of the tree it's a
data structure that can be mapperton is
a tree so all the data model is oriented
on a tree model inside the database
each resource each object that we have
on the database has fields as an eskimo
tool to validate the the field has its
object-oriented it has inheritance so
you can have objects that energy from
other objects and have a static and
dynamic behaviors to change the amount
of fields that we have we will see some
examples later in order to interact with
the user in order to provide a way to
connect data send that and go through
data we are using JSON schema one of the
standards on on the API wall and we have
direct mapping from je schemas to Python
schemas security security is a really
important piece from Gdynia because it
comes from an enterprise CMS and it
allows to define for each object for
each folder for each element on the tree
who has permissions to see who has each
permissions to delete who can get some
information from there who can compute
something on that object etc etc and it
has inherited of permissions also you
can accept somebody has permissions to
this object and all the objects inside
that tree will have permissions to do
the same if you want it have a croute
greatest create read update and delete
API so you can do whatever you want with
the object that you have on under your
database through the HTTP verbs and you
can specify your own and pointer if you
think that you it's based on a single
each one of the first four high level
frameworks that provides I think a yoke
on REST API that makes really really
good results on performance and
scalability because it's not blocking
for getting to the database or doing
whatever network operation you need to
do so it really scales up really really
fast like if anybody's interested on the
numbers I can show you later which which
number do we have here it's based on
HTTP one of the best libraries for doing
it the be serving on
I am 106 it has course cars are
something from web it allows you to wear
from different browsers without any
problem embedded on the on the system it
has what it has WebSocket as it is a
thinker you it allows you to define a
WebSocket connection where you can do
transactions or you can do operation so
you get a model through this WebSocket
connection get feedback for example like
we are going to see how we can train a
model and how you can get the feedback
of how is it training the model through
the WebSocket connection you have the
u.s. that it's a one of the protocols in
to allow upload and download of files in
resumable and in batch mode so you can
do different patches to push a big file
to the system if you want to use you can
put your CSV file every one but you can
use to us to make sure that it's
resumable and there is no problem on
transaction mode its
event based all the other stuff it's
built on a single euro Python so we
support events so you can decide if
anybody push an object of this type do
something train something apply this in
area and inference apply whatever you
want we want to do with that object in
real time there is a registry our
registry is the place where you can
write down your configuration some
specific values you want to for example
you want to store the IP parameters for
your models wherever you can store in
the registry there is a queue an
operational queue in the process itself
so you can decide you can say to the
process a I need to apply this thing I
need to do this operation and that needs
to connect to these places and do what
wherever you want you can have this
queue of operations where you can act
them and then it's going to be executed
when the CPU has time to do it without
stopping serving HTTP requests over to
the client it supports multiple
databases you can mount multiple
databases in the same API so for example
you can decide to have distributed
databases and they are mounted to
different URLs where you can decide each
one right now we have full support for
PostgreSQL and we are going to release
soon the support for co-current they
just released the 1.0 version last week
cockroach if anybody's not knowing is a
distributed database that allows you to
scale horizontally without a lot of
performance loss it supports distributed
transactions that it's really great and
it has the same API protocol than
phosphorus to to be able to talk with it
on this database is what we are storing
is not column information besides they
are squirrel that the basis it's pickle
we are always toward because they're so
our scheme of data can be changed at any
time on on the on the life of the bulk
we also have packages to support storing
large files and binary files on s3 and
were cloud storage we are going to open
source soon the local distributed file
system to have to support storing large
files and/or local distributed system we
support indexing if you want to be able
to search across all your data you can
instability in elastic surges of the
packets that automatically maps your
data that you want to be able to be
searchable across a elastic search
cluster in a way that you can decide
each few from your schema how do you
want to map on the on the elastic search
and give you dinner takes care to
maintain the synchronicity between the
indexer and the real database
it has distributed cache that means that
you can scale up this really fast and it
will go always really fast because there
is a cache that with pops up it provides
invalidation of objects to each of the
of the front-end that you have it has
swagger so I don't know if you know what
swagger is one of the standards on open
API standard for writing api's you can
write your code and automatically
generate the API from swagger in a way
that you can build your connectors in
any language that attacks this API it's
built from containers to support in
containers and it has some great
functionality over on kubernetes for
example in order to scale up
automatically if you deploy visiting on
kubernetes environment we are adding
support to Namit and your orchestration
and engine and everything it's written
with explicit Python so everything is on
the code there is no much configuration
file and you just write your information
on the under Python code
so dinner dinner it's how we took this
16 18 years of knowledge of top clone
and we took the minimal thing that it's
important the all the knowledge that
there isn't at platforms and we build
something from scratch without knowledge
they are only practical we are still
using is one it's called so kind of
interface so I've already explained it
that the API is what we call a traversal
API to wrestle with the eyes a way that
you can map on the URL the tree that
your database is hosting for example in
this case the first element in the URL
is going to be the database then the
next one is going to be the main
container that you are creating object
object and super cheap and super and
then you can ask
operation on that objects using URLs
directly so a bit of summary of what we
do dinner it's only passing through the
ticks it's designed to house millions of
objects we have some instances with 10
million 100 million of objects without
any performance problem it's able to
scale it really really fast and it's
stateless the API right itself so you
can start as many API front-end as you
want
it's we really had a really good work on
memory optimization you can run a video
dinner on 50 megabytes of RAM if you
want if your objects are going to be
really big you need to at least have
four times one object on the size of the
memory but it's really optimized on all
the operations to not consume a lot of
memory it allows us to apply operations
to the objects in a sync mode so you can
say just calculate this for all the
objects and then it's going to take care
for you without a stop in serving all
the security mechanism is really
important so identification and
authorization it's really a core a model
from the guillotine ER it supports all
of those flows to be able to connect to
different or providers and it has a
model API too if you want to extend to
your identification system and one of
the cool things is that as we are doing
the same API that clone has if you all
really need to build some UI for
managing this content you can use all
the UI widgets applications that the
clone community is building to to be
able to manage this information so it's
abused you want to have some kind of CMS
on top of your application of your data
you can have it because you already have
a front-end application built on react
or angular that is able to attack the
same API and do the same operations on
your database
okay so this has been a marketing talk I
will mix selling you a lot this
framework I'm one of the main awesome so
you can you can understand why I'm
selling this so so much so but I really
want to show how easy is to try it okay
so this is the configuration file for
video dinner so the only thing that you
need to define is where you have your
database you're Postgres database in
this case which transaction was a
conflict resolution strategy do you want
we have multiple one of the most common
one is to resolve the conflict you
define which is the schema user database
which is the size of the pool that you
want which part do you want to serve the
API some static resources that you want
to push which is the root password that
allows you to a good subtopic the API
the course configuration and some
utilities so this is my a small config
file it's it's everything that you need
to try give Adina how do you do that
quite easy first we need a database so
in order to the database first we're
using docker we can just bootstrap a
post queries created a database it's
called militina pip install it Athena
give you Tina min you see the config
file I was saying and then you
automatically will have your API serving
at idat port there how you can play with
that okay it's quite easy you can do get
posts and patch and get and delete so
first we can get which is the
information that there is on the root we
can access to the root using the admin
user password and then we can start to
create content how do you through
content so just pushing junction to the
API in a normal way so we do a post post
means creation we create a container we
call it ID container with a title my
lovely container on this 10
that is the database that we mounted
this at the base this DV name is the DB
name that we have here we can have
multiple databases mounted on the same
API so we create the container we can
create a folder inside this container
with this URL you can see now that
you're the base URL we are doing the
post is the URL from the container we
created and we can create another folder
and we can create an item inside this
folder and we can modify the title from
this item on this folder or we can get
again the item or we can delete the
container itself so all the operations
to create modify just HTTP request to
the API and we make sure that if this is
says 200 this is going to be stored in
the database for sure so which is the
data model that all these objects has
inside we already seen that it's a JSON
file there but we splitted the
information into kind of models so the
data is stored in the main object we
call the resource where there is a
schema that defines there is an integral
there is a flow there is text there is a
soup object wherever you want and then
we have a static behaviors and dynamic
behaviors but it's another schema with
other fields that we one can apply
dynamically to the objects to extend the
object in any moment so for example we
can have a shopping cart so shopping car
is an object where we have a list of
fields and then we can decide that this
shopping car has a behavior to say which
is the shipment process and each
behavior can have semantics or different
filter so a bit of code how we define a
content type their account the diaper it
just an interface that we inner it from
an item for example and we just define
this is going to be attacked
or a number or a food or whatever and
then you define with a decorator that
the content died it has this name
belongs to this schema that we defined
here and have these behaviors that you
can define later so this is enough to
create your content type you can define
as many content types
this is quite similar to how Django it's
doing for example this is your RAM with
square alchemy or any other of the web
frameworks that erases how to do the
mapping of the objects to a database so
this automatically creates this kind of
object and we can create them on the
database how we do an event for example
imagine that we want to do something
that happens when we create and this
object which is created so which is the
configure subscriber for this interface
that is the object of we define it with
this event we added this content and we
can define any I think code here that is
going to happen when somebody creates
this object on the database then how we
do our own endpoint a place where we are
going to to be able to call and do some
get operations so we can define the
permission the name and the the method
that we want and then just on this I
think all you can write wherever you
want that it happens when you call this
operation so this it's what is video
dinner right now it's completely stable
we do some production some other
companies are using it a lot at owner we
are using it a lot also so if we if
anybody wants to try feel free to open
issue on the on the g hub repository
it's really great what I really want to
show now is what we are working on the
color on the core contributors for the
next versions that we are going to push
these are working progress most of them
are already finished that are really
oriented to the data scientist world
first what we call the distributed hive
so as I explained this that are this
stateless API the Salish web framework
allows us to bootstrap many of them and
with any problem because they are
stateless so we decided to be able to
create workers for this API we can
bootstrap a different amount of
guiltiness that are in worker mode and
we can distribute operations across all
these workers so imagine that you need
to modify all the objects on your
database or you need to modify all the
objects that are from some specific type
or you need to do some kind of operation
there then you can just start an action
a task that is going to be distributed
along all these objects to be able to
apply to all the amount of users that
monopods that you have it's based on LED
TV ad as the for discovery of the
different workers that we have we can we
support dynamic bootstrapping of
different workers there is no
aggregation callback so right now you
would scrap all the tasks but you don't
get any result it's just in a sync mode
it's going to be done and when it's done
it's done but it's something that will
be great to do and I really want to
thank you Nathan Bengazi
that it's the one who who contribute
more on this package because it's a
really good piece of work this is going
to be called the routine - we're going
to open source in the next weeks on the
repository so how is it work a bit so
just get defined your tasks that your
task that's wherever in this case is
which is getting the object and then in
your code this isn't the worker and your
code is get the utility I hope you do
your fitting and then you can define
this task with the name of the task and
then the parameters that you understand
and then you just push this test so all
the workers are going to receive this
information and it's going to distribute
the load of the operation on the
database
other things that we are building
inference so we are using pencil flow
serving we use a lot of sense of flow
for for a lot of things in ona so we
build a model for video dinner that
allows to bootstrap a tensor flow
serving model let it see and just with a
specific TF loader adapter that gets a
model to apply the inference from the
API so you can store the model on the
API and the serving can decide we from
multiple models which one needs to be
used to do the inference so at the end
you have a URI from a resource you
decide to apply your model and you put
the URI of the model and automatically
get the first tangible serving that has
the my harpy's model it just sends
information there and applies the
inference and update the object with the
confirmation that it's been discovered
from that object and because the the
most experimental thing that we are
working and that I'm really happy about
the records that we are getting is
distributed training we have the
information on the dot on the API itself
so all the model information is there so
we can we train dynamic new models using
tensorflow
just getting all the information we
already have all the data there so it's
just a matter of connecting the two
worlds so yeah we we have with good
results and a good proof of concept
right now that bootstraps workers using
tensorflow
distributed ends of lots of bootstraps
parameter servers and bootstraps workers
that they get connected and
automatically synchronizing using etcd
then we have our own tensorflow
operation that adds access to guillotine
arrest API so all the input variables
are retrieved from the REST API itself
and then we support a different we are
playing this right now with the
reinforcement learning support so it can
apply a reinforcement landing based on
information that we have all the order
interaction from the users are going to
sync to your application framework we
can connect things and all the
interaction all the information that we
are getting we can send to the to the to
the Spencer flow model and the coolest
thing that we started two weeks ago is
there is a inside the bloom community
during something that's called
restricted Python it's a package that
allows us to define a subset of Python
operatives that you can execute so to
make sure that you are not doing crazy
things on Python and providing the
option to write Python code from the web
so you can define a piece of Python and
execute that inside your your
environment so we said what can we use
this technology that we have already on
by Humphry to write down the
architecture that we want to run on
tensorflow
from the data model point of view and
then just extend that to the workers to
be able to execute this this
architecture and it works
we still need to publish a lot of things
and we still need to solve a lot of
problems there but at least it works so
we will be able to allow our data
scientists to kind of write down the
architect way they want to try and just
push to Train something with all the
data in the same production environment
that we have so the main problem that we
are facing and if anybody wants to solve
it G RPC has no I think I your support
and it's a big problem and if anybody
wants to contribute solving this problem
there is an issue tracker on angiopathy
repository a procedure the protocol that
tends to flow is using for communicating
all the processes this is made in
Barcelona this was created here and we
have a really good community
Oscar and Nathan and alerted the bank
contributes to the to the product but we
are still open to a lot of contribution
as if anybody wants to help
product we are really open to to welcome
people an announcement we are going to
do the plum conference on October 16 in
Barcelona the first time we are going to
do this conference in Barcelona it's
going to be a really important
international conference so if anybody
wants to attend we are going to discuss
about these things and a lot of other
techniques about I think you about
fronting about angular about react about
August acknowledges that affects
nowadays web development and at all
thank you thank you I maximum do you
have any questions as your hands how
major is this framework is it already
being used in the industry yeah so I
think we should shut down the cameras
because I'm not allowed now we are using
in production at onin we know some other
companies that are using and yeah it's
ready for production it's a stable it's
really well tested it's a lot of
performance tests as is done there there
is automatic testing of any commit and
there is a high quality knowledge and it
must be everybody that's contributed
comes from 16 years of long knowledge so
there is really good with knowledge for
for building this application it's not
really alt and so guillotine itself it's
six months but they came from pallone
server so we just changed the name and
from server has nearly two years right
now so it's kind of it's stable because
we are using and we have no problems of
memory leakage and its scales with that
the core the different plugins that we
are building may have may be more in
unstable there Thanks more questions
but first thank you for representation I
think the this a very nice piece of
salary that's almost everything is I
don't know is Europe in the hoping for
two years you say people very good
experience and I'm curious about I don't
know you mentioned a thus it has the
kind of index first to discharge for you
something because you have the travel
soul API hmm what do you want to find
all the objects that have certain
attribute or whatever and also what
about the performance of mass operations
there is this thing you mention about
the work in progress but for example
imagining what about if I modify the
schema some interfaces in this case of
some object anyone then I need to add a
default for to sphere for for the
objects and then if I if the system is
on pickle everything and change
something and then pickle it again and
save it if I have 1 million objects is
going to take a lot of time or more than
in a column lorry entered database or
how do you solve this well I understood
there the question about indexing
indexing it's also using elastic search
so we don't want to support indexing in
the database itself because it a lot it
has a lot of transient transaction
ability and it adds a lot of our
overwhelming the the CPU and how do we
link XE so we we just we are using right
now elastic search we have an open
source plug-in for indexing everything
that you want that I did not understand
the side of the second question I mean
since the way the database is done to
store objects you have to do massive
operation like update for all the others
of this kind for this field put here
five how is the performance for this
because in to get wake up all the
objects I remember in salty of this
issue where you're migrating and then
you that so in order to solve that there
is the main way of doing massive
operations it's not based on content
type situation on the tree
for example so our our main use cases
that we've seen and we are we needed to
apply this kind of techniques it's not
applying for all these kind of objects
or just applying for everything that
provides inside this folder or inside
this this node so the architecture of
the database that we are having it's not
geo DB we don't use your divider so it's
our own database model and we designed
the database or a mapping model oriented
to have a really fast waking up of
objects that are in nested inside an
antenna tree so it's a way that we can
have high performance of doing working
across all the objects inside the tree
more questions yes since the data is
pickle in the database how do you handle
a schema evolution over time well so the
schema is on the code and what we saw in
the database is a pickle no so there is
no no you can define to write more a new
field and there is no problem because
it's going to be the file value that is
going to be there in case that it's not
under the under pickle because the
objects from - allows to define of it
automatically wraps the set as reviewed
and the get attribute from the Python
object in order to provide the table
values in custom database in case it
you're removing a field there is no
problem the Pico will have that on the
database but you will not need to have
that and on the ASX so there is no there
is a really few of our cases where you
really need to go to update all the
objects and your if you are most in case
you're renaming on fuel in case that you
need two remaining but it's really few
more a few more cases that your every
name is an attribute it's more that
you're adding new attributes we are
adding attributes every every week and
we like that because we don't whenever
we are not able to define the model from
the day one that's going to survive
forever so it allows us to do that
without problems Thanks
so it's time for lunch
let me tell you that this afternoon we
have lacking tools also so we want to
give a one lightning talk go to the
whiteboard and write down your guilty
talk presentation and now give a bigger
posture oh come on and he's yogi nothing
[Applause]